on se demande souvent quel est le poids
d'un candidat dans l'élection d'un parti
sachant toute l'importance qu'on accorde
aux chefs bas j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle
pour les candidats qui vont se présenter
au prochain scrutin dans les quatre
principaux partis 5200 répondants entre
le britannique en ontario et au québec
jean françois darroux a co réalisé une
étude sur le sujet après les élections
fédérales de 2015
au québec près de 60% des électeurs
n'ont pas de préférence pour un candidat
au delà de son affiliation partisane
évidemment le candidat préféré est
souvent associé au parti préféré mais à
peine 3% des électeurs sont prêts à
changer d'allégeance politique pour
donner leur vote un candidat de leur
circonscription
les candidats jouent mais à la marge ce
qui est beaucoup plus important si les
partis politiques et la campagne
nationale donc essentiellement oui dans
le cas de coûts serrés ça peut faire la
différence
hbo you des numéros scop dans toute
bonne chose en politique à la fois la
vie privée la carrière antérieure de
l'individu que une candidature assez
forte
côté local de terrain par exemple peut
faire une différence qui seraient dans
cette école plus importante
mystérieusement les québécois sont moins
portés vers les candidatures locales
qu'ailleurs au canada
peut-être dire aux certains en raison de
la polarisation entre les mouvements
fédéralistes et souverainistes
cela dit on sait bien que si un candidat
ou une candidate fait une énorme bourde
à la prochaine élection
il ou elle suscitera certainement plus
d'intérêt mais pour les mauvaises
raisons
en plus de mettre son parti dans
l'embarras
[Musique]
à